[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti Sono Paolo Loreto
insegno Startup di impresa
all'Università di Catania corso di
laurea di informatica ma non è solo
informatica è un corso di laurea che
apre ad altri dipartimenti altre facoltà
tutte le ingegnerie fondamentalmente D
Università di Catania ingegneria civile
elettronica elettrotecnica meccanica
edile informatica gestionale più
studenti di economia studenti di
giurisprudenza studenti di Scienze
Politiche morale della favola 450
studenti in aula
mediamente insegno loro Come si fa una
startup per molti di loro
è una
sfida sono tanti li metto a lavorare sul
business plan faccio fare il business
plan di una startup li metto in gruppo e
su 400 450 studenti bene o male ogni
anno vengono fuori 50 70 idee di startup
belle che però devono essere
accompagnate aiutate da un punto di
vista gestionale da un punto di vista
organizzativo da un punto di vista
economico da un punto di vista
finanziario questo è il lavoro che Volgo
e essendo manager di impresa metto a
disposizione le mie competenze
manageriali per aiutare i futuri
startupper a creare la la loro azienda
dei sogni mentre parliamo vi faccio
vedere alcuni dati sul fenomeno delle
startup in Italia come sono cresciute
negli anni cosa
rappresentano ad oggi abbiamo oltre
14.000 startup innovative e
rappresentano quasi il 4% di tutte le
società di capitali presente in Italia
questo 4 sarà il 5 l'anno prossimo sarà
il 6 tra 2 anni sarà il 10 tra 15 Tra 10
anni un numero
importante queste startup sono
localizzate tendenzialmente in Italia
dove vedete la maggiore concentrazione
nelle aree nelle grandi aree di Roma e
Milano che assorbono tanto in Sicilia
abbiamo 715 startup innovative pari al
poco più del 5% del numero di startup in
Italia e Le startup operano
principalmente nel settore dei servizi
e il
56% delle startup innovative nei servizi
ICT information e Communication
Technology intelligenza artificiale big
data blockchain Cloud Cyber Security
automazione e-commerce soluzioni
digitali automazione hardware software
capite bene che io sto nel mezzo Proprio
in pieno li prendo tutti sono tutti gli
startup per miei studenti quelli che
andranno a finire lì dentro e se siamo
bravi a formarli usciranno delle belle
startup Questa è la definizione di
Startup di Steve Blank il
precursore delle startup non mi soffermo
sulla definizione ma vorrei
evidenziare fare una startup
un'esperienza totalizzante che può dare
grandi soddisfazioni come quelle di
cambiare il mondo e vediamo aiutiamoli
questi startup per a cambiare il mondo
ma per fare
questo
bisogna farci alcune domande ci sono
delle domande chiave lo sapete qual è la
domanda chiave che si fa lo startupper o
il mio studente prima di creare una
startup Pensateci un
attimo dovreste creare voi la la startup
una nuova impresa a cosa pensate Ecco lo
sapevo già stanno ridendo qua i soldi
dove prendiamo i soldi no non è questa
la domanda i soldi ci sono Ce ne sono
tanti basta saperli cercare basta
saperli
intercettare Allora può essere l'idea
Forse può essere il team il gruppo di
lavoro Buona domanda o come proteggo la
mia idea dai da quelli che la vogliono
rubare i copicat che me la vogliono
portare via la tengo segreta la divulgo
la comunico agli altri vediamo un po'
queste domande e soffermiamoci su ognuna
di di
queste la mia idea è
innovativa prima domanda ma che vuol
dire innovativo shun Peter dice che
un'idea innovativa un'innovazione
è l'invenzione di un nuovo prodotto di
un nuovo servizio di un nuovo processo o
la modifica di un processo esistente e
basta Questo per Rendere l'idea
innovativa e creare la startup no
affinché la startup sia innovativa e
possa trasformarsi in business deve
risolvere un
problema creare un bisogno
soddisfare un bisogno creare
Convenienza solo se la
startup Attiva uno di questi meccanismi
Allora la mia idea potrà essere
innovativa quale altra domanda potrebbe
esserci sono pronto a creare la
startup siamo in
Italia creare la startup è un'impresa
significa scegliere la forma
giuridica solo società di
capitali principalmente
srl aprire la partita IVA costituire la
società dal
notaio iscriverla al Registro delle
Imprese un casino E allora forse la
domanda potrebbe essere
un'altra ma la vogliamo fare in Italia
Questa
Startup
in Italia significa eccesso di
burocrazia
certezza o meglio incertezza del diritto
incapacità o difficoltà nell'attrarre
capitali esteri Eppure Quindi l'Italia
tecnicamente sembrerebbe un terreno poco
indicato per la startup eppure vi
garantisco per esperienza personale che
l'Italia è un terreno fertile è lo
spazio sarebbe lo spazio ideale per
creare la startup perché abbiamo le
competenze perché abbiamo le tecnologie
perché abbiamo le conoscenze e ci sono
tantissimi casi di startupper che sono
andati all'estero hanno fatto esperienza
sono tornati in Italia e hanno creato
Startup di
successo lo spazio
l'Italia Altra
domanda il
team il team è il biglietto da visita
per la startup quando guardo i miei
studenti o i futuri startupper li guardo
negli occhi e cerco di capire la
motivazione il sacrificio la dedizione
l'impegno che ci metteranno e quanto
credono nella loro idea di impresa se ci
credono loro Forse ci crederò anch'io e
chi li deve finanziare se non ci credono
loro non ci crede
nessuno lavorare sul team sere il gruppo
di persone Giusti scegliere le persone
con il grado di commitment di impegno e
di dedizione può creare può sbloccare un
potenziale umano incredibile e come dice
Steve blan li può portare a realizzare
sogni incredibili come quello di
cambiare il mondo ma non è neanche il
team la risposta giusta piano piano ci
stiamo avvicinando alla domanda più
complessa
il modello di business
Eh il modello di business Ma che è il
modello di business il modello di
business è l'insieme delle attività
delle azioni delle interazioni
dell'organizzazione delle strategie che
deve avere una
startup complicato no perché per fortuna
esistono tanti modelli di business e ve
ne do uno gratuito di hoster
waler business Model Canvas nove blocchi
che spiegano tutto quello che bisogna
fare per creare una startup tutte le
domande a cui dare risposta per creare
una startup è una sorta di reference
book una linea guida e il futuro
startupper deve porsi tutte queste
domande la grande validità del modello è
che è gratuito e che contiene tutto
basta rispondere alle domande o non
rispondere Nel caso non si applica la
nostra idea di business per creare per
studiare mettere in piedi un modello di
business che possa essere
valido ma non è neanche questa la
domanda che si deve porre lo
startupper
Eccola questa eh Vi piace dove prendiamo
i soldi non è questa perché ve l'ho
detto
perché fortunatamente la startup
gode di un fondo di garanzia del mise
Ministero dello Sviluppo Economico che
finanzia fino all' 80% come garanzie per
chiedere un finanziamento
bancario Sapete bene che se andate in
banca e non avete garanzie la banca i
soldi non ve li darà mai sfido uno
startupper nuovo un ragazzo di 25 anni
23 anni 18 anni ad andare in banca e
chiedere un finanziamento senza garanzia
non glielo daranno mai
ma c'è il fondo di garanzia e poi vi
dico anche di più non è la banca lo
strumento migliore
per finanziare una
startup abbiamo il capitale dei soci
l'autofinanziamento le tre F Family la
famiglia Friends gli amici fools i pazzi
che ci seguono quelli che riusciamo a
coinvolgere e cooptare nella nostra idea
di impresa e poi il crowdfunding un
strumento che sta crescendo in maniera
enorme gran parte delle delle startup
Ora sono finanziate sul crowd funding
soprattutto quelle del terzo settore ma
si sta lavorando tanto anche su progetti
di business nei settori un po' più
tradizionali e poi due figure
chiave che accompagnano Le startup i
business Angels e i venture
capitalist gente come me che mette a
disposizione gratuitamente filantrop la
propria esperienza
il
le proprie conoscenze o per chi ce li ha
i propri capitali a disposizione dei
futuri imprenditori e poi ci sono gli
incubatori e gli acceleratori d'impresa
che aiutano e poi i finanziamenti i
premi i Grant Le startup competition
finanziamenti a fondo perduto o a tasso
agevolato tra questi Smart and start di
Invitalia strumenti che funzionano i
soldi ci
sono Non è questo il problema
La vera
domanda è
questa è
questa è il momento giusto per creare la
startup le idee dei miei startupper sono
utili belle ma potrebbero arrivare sul
mercato troppo presto quando ancora il
mercato Non è pronto
oppure potrebbero non trovarsi nella
dimensione
nell'ambiente corretto per realizzare un
progetto
vincente la chiave di una startup si
chiama Time to Market ingresso sul
mercato
tempo tempo di ingresso sul mercato
vabbè Questo lo dico io ve lo
dimostro prendo a prestito un Ted
di Bill Gross che ha presentato uno
studio su tante startup e ha individuato
i fattori chiave gli elementi di
successo di una startup
cinque idee Team modello di business
finanziamenti e tempo guarda caso le
domande che ci siamo fatti poco
fa Facciamo un
gioco
le conoscete queste
startup Sfido chiunque a dire no
Airbnb Instagram Uber YouTube Linkedin
ma perché sono startup erano Quando sono
nate erano startup e le sono state
valutate per ognuna di questi
parametri idea 10
8898 Team 9 9 10 8
10 mo modello di business 8 5 Instagram
avevo un modello di business 5 Eppure
sapere che cos'è
Instagram 5 YouTube quindi forse il
modello di business non è rilevante
finanziamenti Guardate 6 4 7 6 7 numeri
bassi tempo timing 10 9 10 9 8
continuiamo nell'esercizio e queste le
conoscete Se c'è uno che dice sì e sta
imbrogliando
Eppure Guardate il fattore finanziamenti
pallino verde 10 10 10 8 6 sono fallite
Ma come Con tutti quei soldi sono
fallite perché Guardate il tempo pallino
rosso
4 4 5 5
6 capite dove voglio
arrivare ve lo rendo ancora più
facile Ecco quanto conta ognuno dei
fattori che abbiamo visto guardate chi
c'è al primo
posto tempo guardate chi c'è
l'ultimo siete ancora convinti che so
sono il problema delle
startup fattore tempo il tempo è la
chiave la domanda che ci dobbiamo porre
è il momento
giusto è troppo presto per la mia idea e
il mondo non è pronto oppure è troppo
tardi e potrebbero esserci già i
concorrenti hanno eretto barriere
all'ingresso
Io non entro più in un progetto di
impresa il tempo è la chiave per avere
successo Team modello di
business fonti di
finanziamento sono
importanti ma il tempo conta di più
[Applauso]
grazie l